so
you know we used to worry about
scientists covering up
aliens you know the existence of aliens
but now i think we have to worry about a
different kind of sort of uncovering the
new york post reports this week
nasa to launch naked pictures of humans
to space in hope of attracting aliens
now
i want to make contact with aliens as
much as the next guy
apparently not quite as much
we need to seriously think about about
the sort of contact
that we want to actually have with these
creatures
and i mean look at our attempts to reach
out to aliens have been so far as far as
we know unsuccessful
if this is what finally earns a response
i'm not sure that's a good sign if they
were ignoring us up until now and then
we send we send naked pictures out and
now they respond
i i just i don't what's the strategy
this is another area where i'm confused
about the strategy now if we're hoping
to avoid a visitation then i could maybe
understand sending out pictures of uh i
don't know you know lizzo or something
for example that would surely dissuade
any intelligent race from landing here
but avoidance is apparently not the plan
this is from the new york post it says
nasa scientists plan to launch pictures
of naked humans into space in the hope
of luring aliens to us
the depictions will also include an
invitation to respond
should an intelligent alien race find
them
the pictures aren't graphic photographs
of naked humans but a drawing of a naked
man and a woman next to a depiction of
dna the man and woman are waving in an
attempt to look more inviting
nasa scientists revealed the image in a
study that's part of a project called
the beacon in the galaxy
the main aim of the bitg project is to
send a message to any alien
civilizations that could be out there
oh so that's our excuse for stalking e.t
with unsolicited nudes
and if he's offended we're just going to
say what hey
sorry man we just wanted to show you our
our beacon and here's my question
what if e.t
sends nudes back
are we really prepared to see that
i am certainly not
and like i said what if he does more
than return the favor what if this is
really
the thing that draws them here
what if as the poet once said uh the
milkshake really does bring
the boys to the yard what
then the perverts or nasa are going to
get us all turned into sex slaves
here's think about this way 50 years ago
and i'll stop talking about this in a
second
50 years ago scientists were landing
humans on the moon
and now because apparently only fans is
running the space program we are
flashing an entire alien civilization
from 90 million light years away
and it actually gets worse because and i
haven't looked this up but i'm pretty
sure about this
um this this uh this uh uh deep space
probe shall we call it that we're
sending out this is actually not the
first of its kind because i'm pretty
sure that there was a probe in the 70s i
think it was the pies either the voyager
of the pioneer thing was the pioneer
where we also sent naked pictures
and that craft is now wandering through
space
50 billion miles away totally ignored
so we slid into the aliens dms with
naked pictures they ignored us and now
we're so desperate that we're sending
another one
it's like the anthony weiner strategy of
galactic diplomacy i guess
um
which is why i suggest a compromise
really which is that um rather than
sending the naked pictures let's just
send
the aliens pictures of
uranus instead
that was the worst joke of the bunch i
had to do it though i mean i just can't
like i'm a dad it's you've got the
uranus joke we're laying right there
you've got to make it and so that's it
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends